جاءت الخطوه غير المسبوقه تاريخيا كاقيه
من حزب الرئيس بايدن على نفاذ صبر اعضائه
من التحديات العلنيه لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي لمناشدات الرئيس الامريكي
واقتراحاته بشان الحرب في غزه وفتره ما
بعد
الحرب كثيرون يعتقدون ان وجود علاقه عمليه
مع نتنياهو اصبح امرا مستحيلا لانه لا
يستمع لما فيه مصلحه اسرائيل او الولايات
المتحده الامتعاض من مواقف وتصريحات رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي انتقل ايضا الى مجلس
النواب حيث وقع 44 نائبا ديمقراطيا رساله
حثوا فيها البيت الابيض على العمل لانجاح
حل
الدولتين ان زعماء الحزب الديمقراطي
يقولون الان كفى انه تطور كبير لكنه لن
يغير الوضع بشكل جذري لان الامر سيتطلب
قرارا من بايدن وعلى الرغم من الرمزيه
التاريخيه لخطوه المشرعين الديمقراطيين
تبدو فرص تبنيها من الحزبين مستبعده
للغايه مع بدايه موسم المزايده
الانتخابيه بغض النظر عن مصير التعديل
المقترح ستكون له تداعيات داخل الحزب
الديمقراطي كما انه يشكل بالفعل قطيعه
تاريخيه
داخل مجلس داب على الاختلاف حول كل شيء
باستثناء الدعم غير المشروط لاسرائيل محمد
العلمي الجزيره واشنطن